thank you
[Music]
welcome to a very strange episode of
careful boys where um we happen to be
short on the number of people so instead
of just having a giant blank seat we
decided to just pull everything together
and just get slightly closer and have a
little bit of fun with the format so cat
doesn't like it he said
the minutes before recording he said he
hated it I don't like this I didn't say
that this is different what's your top
five reasons why you don't like this oh
I'm glad you asked me because I have a
list prepared
um no well Walter keeps saying we're
gonna win
five minutes before I think he's talking
about Super Bowl were you talking about
the Super Bowl he always was talking
about Super Bowl you know like the
general consensus is probably Super Bowl
however being as like how today is like
this and we're on one side and you're on
the other side and we have a moderator
yeah
I can't help but think that we're gonna
win all right so that's a good idea why
don't we do this
um just start the base since Bart and
Joe are both not here yeah our fearless
leaders let's talk about Barton Joe okay
you guys are team Bart you guys are team
Joe okay let's discuss the pros and cons
of each I don't want to do that
the reason why I don't want to do it and
we can still do it okay but as soon as
you say as soon as you say I'm team Bart
I immediately want to root for team Joe
okay I immediately have negative things
to say about bart and I have positive
things to say about Joe I'm Bart what
would you say yeah you lost weight it's
like hey I'm touching Nick all the time
okay what do you really think of Bart
um I actually really like Bart a lot
I really like Bart uh recently there was
a video of him touching my penis on uh
on camera really yeah yeah are you
admitting when you guys are like play
fighting are you accusing him yeah I
think I think the bit was or was it like
at Lionheart like a different no no it
was a bit was he was a Korean uncle
right oh yeah I think Jesus was here and
you actually you and Jesus kind of
jumped me also that was that was like a
video clip but he's like pointing at my
my wiener and yeah he grabs it and I was
like
yeah yeah and I felt like he was my
Korean Uncle okay so I'm hearing a lot
of Pros yeah I need to need to get a
condoms it was too short that was the
con I have a question we have a question
why does it have to be Korean uncle oh
[__] sorry we need to provide context I
guess like I guess I'm losing Bart was
saying that that in Korean culture they
have a different level of homosexual
humor
well you know you just look at me
in Korea like okay so here's it's a lot
more open I don't know if you guys ever
been to a Korean club like back in the
Heyday like in the early odds like in
K-Town yeah Colleen goes there a lot
that's it was the only Club where uh you
can see two guys dancing with each other
they're dancing with each other but
they're actually out there they need a
reason to go out there to like look for
girls they'd rather go by themselves
they're just plotting you go together
and then guys would dance in a circle
together or like two of three or
whatever that's the only Club you could
do that where no one's like oh because
you know back then in the early odds
like like are they gay like you could
say stuff like that you can't really say
that now
they do inside I hear it said about me
all the time
but yeah it's a favorite game but in
Korea it's not like you can see guys
like they'll say like well they're Femme
they might be gay but they're just
friendly it's not a it's not a thing for
them like where it's like oh they're
active they're acting you know
homosexual or they might be gay they're
strategizing there's way more openly
yeah about it yeah it's not a big deal
oh what is it called homoeroticism yeah
that's not what that so that's a little
bit different
huh do you feel better about it no no it
didn't bother me I'm sorry if I didn't
seemed like it was bothering me I was
gonna ask if like the lights were on or
off if that makes a big difference when
you got touched cameras are on as well
too
it just caught me off guard that's what
it was so I guess it's not really a pro
it's not really a con either it's more
of a surprise of anything like it just
caught me off guard but is it most like
exciting eroticism like being caught off
guard like that feeling yeah man to man
at least right yeah more fun it's like
you're like you're shocked at the same
time you're like huh that's how it was
in the clip if you watch that's how he
was The O Part I didn't really get to
express out loud because it's more
silent and it's more for myself you want
to know you want to know how you know
Nick was okay with it he's he's trained
to reflex in like a hundred different
ways of counter measures and he used
none of them
this guy has a million techniques on how
to deter an opponent and he went hey
come on hey whoa that's a big idea I
made a big deal
what's your top three uh Joe moments Joe
moments
uh let me think about Joe it's usually
him
ah I don't know man because he's so
Random all the time dude my favorite and
this is like my by far my favorite thing
because I have to watch everything when
I'm editing and uh
on on my side like when I'm sitting next
to him the amount of minutes where he's
just going like this
[Laughter]
because I always have to cut away from
like the shorts and like move the thing
he's just going
but I'll say the flip side because I sit
where Colleen is with him sometimes he's
like he's either doing that or he's like
looking away but then also sometimes
he's looking right at me and he's and
he's going like this
it's a joke or something like that and
he's waiting for me to catch eyes or
something he makes eye contact before he
you know that's about to say something
funny yeah it's funny because if like if
for everyone watching like when you
observe Joe he's either like that or
he's like super tart yeah or the thing
the only thing in between is when he's
like checking to make sure the camera is
recording yeah he's like just go
if we had all three cameras on it at the
same time so just so you could see what
Joe's doing well yeah everything else
you know what though that is a thing
because
I think people don't really know what
how much else is going on sometimes when
we're [__] talking yeah because the
camera's on two of one table right right
but there can be stuff going on not to
the outside yeah exactly yeah right so I
bet for you what kind of what kind of
[__] is super annoying for you to edit
nothing it's funny when Nick and I are
talking yeah almost like sometimes I
want to show the other things even
though they're not even talking it's
because of the reactions like the stuff
you guys do on the side while like
Ryan's talking or somebody's talking I'm
like dude I'm just gonna show that
because it's funny dude me and Joe
absolutely ruined the whole video
because
um [__] Steve Green made a joke about
Anthony's uh kinjabang noodles and he
called it the first straight to garbage
Noodle
and a mean joke the whole video couldn't
stop laughing we ruined the rest of the
video because we weren't here we
couldn't contribute anything else other
than laughing that is contributing
though that's that makes it really funny
but it got to the point where Bart had
to cut it just go I almost wait for you
guys to finish
they're the ones that are kind of the
instigators of the silly goose time
right so as soon as they have to stop
one of them has to say something you're
like all right I guess I took it too far
and it's also the fact that Steve called
it the like first straight to garbage
Noodle and then Anthony's face is just
like
oh that's so funny like Anthony if he
didn't react that way it's not as funny
right yeah yeah and Anthony's reaction
is like his soul
is it true then
yeah it's not marketed
it's not really it's not part of the
marketing the street team wouldn't say
that
so you guys have tried then he's good
we wouldn't make fun of it if it wasn't
like as good as it is because it's
actually good if it was bad boxes man if
it was bad we'd be trying to cheer him
up that it's good yeah but because it's
so good you have to say that or he'd
like offer it to us and be like oh yeah
thanks yeah no I already ate oh no it's
okay I have sons at home we actually
sold we got three boxes I bought three
boxes because there's a deal like a
cyber monday deal or something like that
and I do buy full price do you still
have three boxes
I wish there were more flavors but now
they're they're flavors so I haven't
tried the new flavors have you guys so
tell them the new flavors I don't know
look at the camera [__] tunnel do you
flavor the new flavors are uh they have
a spicy one Ken jam and it uh makes you
want to dance when you eat it
it's that part that's not the tagline
they're not trying to go bankrupt
if you want to dance
no that like but that'd be like funny
though like you're watching like an ad
and it's like a Ramen ad it's like all
cooled and then at the very end it makes
you want to dance you're like wait what
did I because you're not paying
attention to ads yeah and then all of a
sudden it makes you want to dance you're
like what and then you're like no way
and then he starts doing it but you
would actually if you saw that as a
marketing campaign you'd say I'm never
buying these [__] noodles dude no you
don't be cool though everyone you know
how scary typically like black people
dance better than everyone in the world
yeah no that's a that's an objective you
know those racist commercials that China
and Italy did were like uh the guy the
black guy they put him in like the the
washing machine
you've never seen these commercials
Italy had one first and then China had
one and then when uh they're like oh
China's racist they brought up the Italy
one again they're like oh it's like it's
not just us it's the whole world what
would be crazy is the opposite is like
if I'm eating the ramen oh it makes me
dance and then I turn black yeah no
that's two races no that would be like
I'm not sure like is it racist and
against who
or Koreans
but then it would just be against me
yeah because Korea because aren't there
some Koreans on the the um the
Jabberwockies or is it yes yes
dude like song dude oh yeah Ben Ben's
Korean
um
solid gold in junior high but
I know it is solid gold was like so like
another American Bandstand
solid gold was kind of like the
the lower rent Black Version if I may
okay
how long were you on the show for I
wasn't on the show that way I was at
videopolis back then amusement park she
just had dance clubs so Disneyland had
videos
oh dude it was awesome so they would
play music videos and then you know like
Junior High kids and high school kids
would dance well solid gold was there
just filming people oh and then I
happened to be one of the guys what did
you do I was doing footwork oh and then
um
I forgot what we call like we call it
suicides back then when you dropped back
you know like you you dropped back and
then you land on your hand and then you
kick your legs up
um and then I was doing this one thing
where you fold you fold your legs you go
down and then you jump up and you do it
just drop in a half split you pull
yourself up like that that was later I
was like honestly that's just like a
year later I think you drop yourself
down yeah pull yourself up that was like
another guy yeah what do they call that
like the dude in the what is it called
the bed the bad video with the skates
and he does it yeah
hey wait
and his arms are like this
imagine you have a third arm that's your
choice to use it yeah yeah dance moves
that's pretty tight why not yeah there's
those guys that break dance and you know
that are double jointed and they make a
dance there's a whole crew and they're
called ill abilities and they're all
disabled in different ways oh but
because of that they use their
disabilities to they're basically super
humans now that's pretty like like a
like some of them have like undeveloped
legs where their like legs are really
small and they just don't laugh
don't make me laugh by you laughing I
know I was and I want to be honest were
you thinking your head like is there a
jiu jitsu team like that no no no
okay oh [__] oh [__] oh [__] dick okay
and it's not because of the uh like uh
the name is the
name is cool
you did this with your hands like they
have small legs and I was like you don't
have to do that with your hand
dude
you didn't have to do that
you mean wait no I have a question
you did this and I was like wait I have
a question though what would long legs
oh yeah
dude it just caught me off guard and
then I I tried to not I shouldn't have
looked at you when I explained it yeah
and you know why because we're way
closer than we normally go
that your eyes are like
we're almost yeah we're too close yeah
they're so good Nick I believe they're
[__] good man they're really good hey
Nick I take it back y'all waiting right
now yeah
I have a question
what are we playing for what if you were
when you were at solid gold in like at
dance clubs and stuff back in the day
did black dudes have a nickname for you
no you okay so we were very ethnocentric
like in like junior high school so like
we only hung out with like Koreans like
in other Asians okay and then plus the
schools I went to didn't have a lot of
black people so you're self-segregated
pretty much but then like when we go to
like those dance clubs like Studio K or
like videos and stuff no you know there
wasn't like
um it wasn't like everyone people were
just dancing no one was really like oh
hey black people are over there Asians
it wasn't like that everyone was there
was an emcee to designate
there was no Usher like oh Korean you're
over here I don't think DJs like that
anymore
and back then knots and uh Disneyland
were cheap to go to oh yeah yeah knots
was crazy if you go at one o'clock it
was like nine dollars it was half up and
then Disneyland was like 20 25 at like
uh like so there's the half day at
Disneyland wow so when do you think
[Laughter]
you know now they don't have happy I
think knots might have half day but they
don't have clubs because there's people
you know we can't have nice things in
America yeah because people screw it up
there were stabbings people would fight
people get stabbed sometimes yeah people
getting stabbed a Toontown there's not
even death you see there was a video uh
recently uh of a family at Disneyland
and they started getting a face at the
picture
right by the tickets yeah
like okay let's just say um we're taking
a photo and they're like Ryan's in the
way and then we're like excuse me hey
we're gonna take a photo real quick and
then they he moves but then his family
wants to take a photo and then we're not
moving oh and then so people got upset
yeah and they got physical you should
fight it yeah and then like and then you
see you know people are shooting the the
fight you see people come out of like
like off screen off camera just coming
in yeah they want to join in on the fun
right yeah I think so like but you know
like I think it's like oh my family's
getting like they're fighting oh I mean
it's the happiest place in the world
totally they're having a lot of fun but
people do [__] at Disneyland that
deserve them to get beat up I think yeah
but this is why though like they have
ushers at Disneyland for photo ops
because in the beginning when I first
saw it I was like why why and then you
realize it makes sense keep a line and
they're good about it because you know
people try to cut like I won't say which
race they are but like even Chinese
people try to cut yeah and then they'll
be like excuse me hey it's very true
you've got it you gotta wait and then
then I try to cut and then but I have to
say though Chinese people are the best
at the surprise like I didn't know yeah
they're like oh there's a lot I didn't
know and then they'll go to the back you
know you know where they also do that
too that's the end outline bro Chinese
people yeah
[Laughter]
depending on what they have dangling
from the rear view uh oh they they cut
the drive-through line you guys bro yeah
they cut the drive through oh it's like
those red do they have the cat yeah bro
you know the uh accessories where
they're like that's a Chinese guy or a
woman and then they go to the front and
then and it's so funny because
somebody's like they start honking and
they'll talk to the in and out person
like that person that person cut they
cut right there and they're like thank
you for telling me and then the guy has
to run up oh well that's cool that they
actually try to alleviate it yeah
because over in the Hollywood in and out
it's notorious for having
um the line to get in the drive-throughs
on the road right and then someone
always comes from the other side and
they cut and thinks that they can just
get in there and then it just everyone
loses their [__] yeah oh yeah no like in
OC where it's beautiful and all the cool
crew people live they actually designed
it in and out they pre-design it so they
plan out where the cars are gonna the
Chinese line is yeah
I like a lie to you there was one time
they had closed because they all have
they'll have two lines that merge into
one yeah and so they take their orders
and they do all that but this the second
line was closed but I saw off
um I I can't say they were Chinese but
they were Asian yeah and they were
trying to go into that one I think in
your hearts in my heart and my toes
based on the content of their character
yeah based on the kind of car they have
yeah and the cat hanging out the back
um I think we got beef now Walter
routine we got beef dude well we're
we're already adversaries that's the way
this is situated sorry I interrupted you
it's all polite
but I'm gonna [__] destroy you but
like the workers were good about like
hey no no this is closed you guys got to
go to the the back of this lawn yeah
yeah and oh see they they actually
closed and in and out to redesign the
Magnolia one no there's what it's one in
a Fullerton because they were the cars
waiting on the road so they're like oh
she's like we can't have any of this
yeah so they redesigned it so where
they're waiting on on the property yeah
it's it's tough man it's in and out's
fault for being too good yeah same thing
that's happening in Chick-fil-A yeah
they got a redesign
would you say you wouldn't even say as
the kids would say nowadays they go in
and out as mid you wouldn't say it's mid
uh I would say straight to trash
the garbage straight to uh not my choice
the idea like something just
[Laughter]
so you got the whitest Skin Man on this
side
yeah
[Music]
foreign